how do you find your passion I got an
email it's a kind of a heartbreaking
email that came in from one of my
newsletter readers Terry I'm gonna share
some of it today and hopefully we can
end on a positive note she writes in a
Sam 37 I'm unemployed and I'm literally
literally counting down the days to my
end my greatest desire to be an
entrepreneur to be totally enveloped in
something I love to do something that
gives me purpose and pleasure in life I
don't have to make millions of dollars
but I'd love to work towards something
that gives me purpose the only thing is
I have no clue as to what that thing is
that I'm supposed to do
I simply don't know my purpose I know
what I enjoy what gives me joy but again
is it a passion to be turned into a
profitable venture to sustain a family
on she goes on and talks about how her
passion is her ministry and she's
thinking about making publications books
magazines she has another obstacle that
she started her own business she's so
discouraged about life that I don't know
where I can start a business I don't I
know I can't live my life in suspense
like this anymore it's tormenting being
unemployed and absolutely no income it's
depressing in itself please help me I'm
at my breaking point Terry I'm really
sorry to hear that you're going through
this the the good thing from this that I
would take is that you want to start a
business around something that you are
passionate about and has a has a purpose
and just that even though you don't know
what you want to do yet just having that
alone puts you ahead of so many other
entrepreneurs who are starting up right
now because people often start for the
wrong reasons they start just trying to
make money
they have no purpose and they end up
losing money and having to go back and
get a job and live a life that they're
unhappy with so your desire to start a
business around something that that is
purposeful for you is the place to start
and you're asking the right questions
and when you start asking the right
questions you start getting the right
answers so you're on the right path even
though it looks bleak and you don't know
where its leading you are on the right
path and I want you to believe that I'm
terms of
business to start you know I have a
whole zuga guide that I walk people
through how to find their passion and to
try to kind of summarize that for you
you want to think about the things that
bring you joy and that add value to
other people's lives
okay things that you are passionate
about that you love doing that you can
get lost in that when you start at 9:00
in the morning and you look up and at
6:00 at night you're still going and you
don't know where the day went because
you love doing this so much combine that
with what adds a lot of value to
people's lives because you have to make
money from this business and it's going
to come money comes from helping people
the more you help people in a meaningful
way the more money you're gonna make so
to combine those two things something
that you absolutely love doing with
something that adds value to people's
lives that's the foundation of your
business and don't let the fear of
having the right idea hold you back if
you have some ideas around the ministry
and that's what you love doing and
preaching and helping people with just
start something start something small
start something on the side start
something without spending a lot of
money on it just start something and
you'll see if it's for you or not you'll
see by the looks on the people's faces
if this is something that that is your
purpose or not here's how I discovered
mine okay I just sold my business I
didn't know what I was gonna do I was
kind of bouncing around with different
ideas and I did a talk with the YMCA and
they said can you come and talk to our
entrepreneurs and I said sure why not
I'm happy to share my message I love
that and I bent weeks preparing and I
promoted this as a free event they
promoted it and I went into the room all
excited to deliver my presentation and
there were only three people there and
it and I'm like three people come really
like after all this promotion and all
the work that I put into making this
presentation three people showed up and
for most people that would have been
failure you know you look at that
business logically rationally like you
could only get three people to show up
between your efforts and between the
YMCA's efforts
on people three people show up for a
free event are you serious this is a
stupid business idea what are you doing
but but I just loved it I got up I did
my thing I helped those three people
that day they came out different people
than when they came in
I had an impact and that made me feel
good and I had to do it again and again
and again and I didn't know what the
format was gonna be and it's evolved
into this it's evolved into a youtube
channel and a popular website and I
would never have predicted that this is
this would be the path I only started
following something that I was excited
about and that I knew felt good and I
knew was helping people so you can't
plan the whole thing you don't know what
you're gonna look like in 10 years but
nothing's gonna happen unless you do
something so start today with something
if it's the ministry start with
something if it's the books the
magazines pick one thing that you're
excited about and start with that and
see if it works and see if you get the
reaction that you want from people and
see if you feel it in your heart that
this this is what you were meant to do
this is your purpose you're not going to
really find your purpose until you start
actually trying some of the things you
have in your head and it will come I
promise you when it feels right it'll
come and and it's almost overwhelming
like this this is what I've been
searching for and you may not get it the
first time or the second time the third
time but keep trying keep reaching out
keep trying to find your passion you are
on the right path and the answer will
come to you if you start taking action
small steps immediately right now
believe for those of you watching like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below that's what keeps me going that's
what keeps me making these videos for
you let me know what you think leave a
comment underneath tell me how you found
your passion if you have a question for
your business leave it in a section
below I'll make a video response
subscribe to the channel if you like
what you're seeing and you want to see
more thank you so much and I'll see you
soon